Seguro que todos habréis tenido esta discusión
alguna vez con vuestros amigos ¿Por qué
suben tanto los precios de los alquileres?
Da igual que viváis en Madrid, Los Ángeles
o Ciudad de México: se trata de un problema
global. Aunque la primera pregunta que nos
deberíamos hacer es… ¿Realmente es un
problema o es algo natural?
Hablamos de un fenómeno que se está dando
en casi todas las grandes ciudades. Por ejemplo,
en Los Ángeles, los alquileres han crecido
en un 15% en los últimos 3 años. Si tienes
un sueldo alto, no es un gran problema. Ahora
bien, vamos a imaginar que eres un empleado
en una tienda de Los Ángeles. Ganas un sueldo
de 2000 dólares al mes. Pues bien, un piso
de 50 metros cuadrados de una sola habitación
en la zona Sur, que es lo más barato, te
puede salir por 1200 dólares. Esto es un
60% de tu sueldo. El resto, a duras penas
te da para comida, ropa y gastos básicos.
En otras palabras… que apenas vas a poder
ahorrar.
Para que os hagáis una idea, según varios
estudios, la situación ideal es que la vivienda
suponga un tercio de tus ingresos para que
puedas ir ahorrando. Pero este empleado de
tienda está al borde de la pobreza. Basta
con que suba un poco más su alquiler para
que termine en bancarrota. Y aquí si que
estaríamos hablando de un más real de lo
que parece…
La población homeless in Los Ángeles crece
dramáticamente hasta llegar a las 36.000
personas
¡Pero no sólo eso! Pensadlo bien… en VisualPolitik
siempre os decimos que el mundo está mejorando.
Cada vez somos más ricos, más sanos y vivimos
mejor. Y esto se debe, en buena medida, a
que la tecnología ha permitido que las cosas
sean más baratas. Por ejemplo, en los años
70, sólo el 20% de los estadounidenses había
viajado en avión ¿por qué? Pues porque
un Los Ángeles-Nueva York costaba el equivalente
actual a 1500 dólares. Hoy, ese mismo vuelo
vale alrededor de 200 dólares. Gracias a
eso, seguro que cualquiera de vosotros ha
volado en avión y ha viajado que vuestros
abuelos. Lo mismo ocurre con casi todos los
bienes de consumo… ¡Menos uno! La vivienda.
Da igual que compremos o que alquilemos: tendremos
que seguir haciendo los mismos o más sacrificios
que las generaciones anteriores. Para que
os hagáis una idea, en pleno 2019, hay gente
en Estocolmo que vive en un piso de 15 metros
cuadrados. De hecho, en Suecia no es raro
que las parejas que se quieren divorciar,
esperen varios meses, simplemente porque es
complicadísimo encontrar un piso para el
cónyuge que se tiene que marchar. Pero ¿Por
qué suben tanto los alquileres? ¿Se puede
solucionar este problema con mejores políticas?
Hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
OFERTA, DEMANDA Y… ALGO MÁS
Es un hecho universal y lógico. La población
crece en todos los países. Para que os hagáis
una idea, hace sólo 10 años, Estados Unidos
tenía 300 millones de habitantes. En menos
de una década han sumado 27 millones más.
Sin embargo, no todas las ciudades crecen
igual. Por ejemplo, Detroit o Cleveland están
perdiendo población ¿Y a dónde se van?
¡Exacto! A ciudades más prósperas como
Los Ángeles, Nueva York o San Francisco que
están creciendo como la espuma. En otras
palabras, la demanda de casas en estos sitios
se dispara ¡Pero atentos porque aquí viene
el auténtico problema! Veréis, en cualquier
otro mercado, es fácil subir la oferta para
satisfacer a la demanda. Por ejemplo, vamos
a hablar de nuestro mercado favorito, el del
Zumo de Dinosaurio. Si Arabia Saudita quiere,
puede aumentar o reducir la producción de
barriles diarios de un mes para otro. Y lo
mismo pasa con cualquier otro país petrolero.
De hecho, esto ocurre muy a menudo y lo hemos
contado millones de veces aquí, en VisualPolitik.
Sin embargo, necesitamos años para construir
un edificio ¡Y no sólo eso! Mucha gente
piensa que el negocio de la construcción
es extremadamente rentable. Que todos los
promotores son millonarios. Pero lo cierto
es que construir un bloque de viviendas requiere
inversiones millonarias y los márgenes de
beneficio rondan el 3% Y lo cierto es que
necesitamos muchas, muchísimas casas nuevas
para cubrir la demanda.
California necesitaría construir 3.5 millones
de unidades de vivienda para 2025 si quiere
cerrar su brecha inmobiliaria –Extracto
de un informe de McKinsey Global Institute,
Octubre de 2016
¿Pero por qué no se construyen más casas?
A fin de cuentas, si hay tantísima demanda,
sería un negocio redondo ¿Verdad? Pues sí.
Sólo hay un pequeño problema: los planes
urbanísticos. Básicamente el mercado del
suelo está hiper regulado por los ayuntamientos.
Si quieres construir una casa en Los Ángeles,
necesitas un permiso que, dependiendo del
barrio, puede tardar hasta 3 años. Y esto
ocurre porque los ayuntamientos son los que
deciden dónde y cómo se puede construir.
Y, claro ¿Cómo sabe el Ayuntamiento si puede
o no permitir hacer más viviendas? Pues principalmente,
con la población. Hasta ahora, los Ángeles
ha ampliado el parque de viviendas casi al
mismo ritmo que crecía la población ¿El
problema? Que la demanda es mucho más alta.
Por ejemplo, el hecho de que cada vez haya
más gente soltera o que aumente la tasa de
divorcios también aumenta la demanda. Pensadlo
bien, una pareja de casados son 2 personas
en una casa. Pero si esa pareja se divorcia,
automáticamente necesitan una casa más.
La población no ha crecido pero la demanda
se ha duplicado.
De nuevo, hemos usado el ejemplo de Los Ángeles.
Pero algo parecido ocurre en Madrid, Berlín
o cualquier gran ciudad. Muchos dicen que
la solución es construir más casas. Otros
dicen que la solución sería liberalizar
el mercado de la vivienda. Pero en Europa,
muchas ciudades están apostando por todo
lo contrario: poner controles a los precios
¿Y qué creéis que está pasando? ¿Es una
buena idea? Pues a mismo lo vamos a ver.
EL AUTÉNTICO SÍNDROME DE ESTOCOLMO
Normalmente, cuando se habla de Suecia es
para ponerlos como un ejemplo a seguir. Los
suecos disfrutan de un estado del bienestar
muy generoso y, a la vez, tienen una economía
abierta con empresas punteras. Entre otras
está la startup más famosa de Europa. Aunque
tal vez no se queden en el país por mucho
tiempo. Atentos.
Spotify amenaza con dejar Suecia y agita una
protesta de startups en Estocolmo
¿Y por qué las starups se quieren ir de
Suecia? ¿Por los impuestos altos? ¡Pues
no! La razón es porque no pueden contratar
talento de fuera del país. Y diréis… ¡Pero
a ver, Fonseca! ¡Si Suecia es un país super
abierto a la inmigración! Pues sí, lo es
sobre el papel. Ahora bien, si queréis mudaros
a Estocolmo ¡Buena suerte encontrando piso!
Mientras hacía este vídeo hablé con un
chico que trabajó para una startup sueca
durante año y medio. Cobraba un sueldo de
unos 2900 euros al mes. Pero más de la mitad
se le iba en pagar el alquiler. Y no el caso
más dramático. Encontrar un piso en Estocolmo
es tan complicado que mucha gente llega a
estar varios meses en un AirBNB. Y diréis
¿Por qué? Pues todo empieza en los años
50. Por aquel entonces, Suecia necesitaba
casas. Y el gobierno socialdemócrata se puso
manos a la obra: construyeron más de 1 millón
de casas en unos pocos años. La idea es que
estas casas se pondrían en alquiler por un
precio muy reducido. Durante esos años, todos
los suecos podían solicitar una vivienda
de protección oficial y vivir con alquileres
de unos 300 o 400 euros de hoy en día. Pero
las cosas cambiaron en los años 90. Por estos
años, Suecia se sumió en una de las peores
crisis de su historia. Y sin dinero, el Gobierno
ya no podía construir más casas. Así que
todas esas obras se pararon en seco. Sin embargo,
todas las regulaciones al alquiler persistieron.
Y, creedme, la situación no podía ser peor.
Por un lado, tenemos lo que llaman el “alquiler
de 1ª mano” que son las viviendas de protección
oficial. Básicamente, lo primero que hace
un sueco cuando cumple los 18 años es registrarse
en la base de datos de viviendas de protección
oficial. Si tiene suerte, dentro de 13 o 16
años le llamarán diciéndole que por fin
puede encontrar su apartamento de 2 habitaciones
en el centro de Estocolmo por el módico precio
de 600 euros al mes. En otras palabras, que
lo que no se paga con dinero, se paga con
tiempo de espera. Y esto explica por qué
el 25% de los suecos no deja la casa de sus
padres hasta los 30 años. De hecho, esto
también explica por qué Suecia está pasando
de ser una sociedad de inquilinos a una de
propietarios.
Pero… ¿Y qué pasa con los que no somos
suecos? ¿Qué pasa si eres un inmigrante
y no tienes una familia con la que quedarte?
Pues bien, en ese caso, bienvenido al maravilloso
mundo del alquiler de segunda mano, que podríamos
llamarlo como el auténtico síndrome de Estocolmo.
Los suecos piensan que hacer negocio con el
alquiler es malo.
Así que, de entrada, sólo hay unas pocas
casas que pueden poner el piso en alquiler
legalmente. Pero, incluso aunque la ley se
lo permite, la comunidad de vecinos puede
prohibírselo ¡Habéis oído bien! En este
país, tu comunidad de vecinos puede decirte
que no alquiles, o que no renueves tu contrato
con el inquilino. De hecho, también hay topes
para los contratos de alquiler. Es muy normal
encontrar contratos de 6 meses, por ejemplo.
Y eso explica que, en un país con un nivel
de vida tan alto, tengamos a gente que vive
en apartamentos de 15 metros cuadrados ¡Es
lo mejor que han podido encontrar! Pero, de
nuevo, el mayor problema no es la incomodidad.
El mayor problema… es este.
Suecia investiga los disturbios en un suburbio
para inmigrantes de Estocolmo
¡Exacto! Los inmigrantes más pobres no tienen
una startup que les busque un piso. Así que
se concentran en las zonas más pobres y generan
guettos. Y sí, ya sé que todos habéis visto
vídeos conspiranoicos que exageran la violencia
en estos guetos de Suecia. Pero, seamos honestos,
aunque no sea tan grabe como lo pintan algunos
medios, Suecia tiene un problema de criminalidad
del que hablaremos algún día. Por cierto,
si sois nuevos en este canal y os está gustando
este vídeo, suscribíos y dadle a la campanita
para que os llegue una notificación al móvil
cada vez que publicamos. Sacamos vídeos todas
las semanas y siempre son igual de interesantes.
Volviendo al tema que nos ocupa, esta crisis
de Estocolmo se podría resolver construyendo
más casas. Pero por mucho que levanten 80.000
viviendas nuevas al año, como proponen muchos,
necesitan cambiar sus leyes de alquiler o
no servirá de nada. Y ahora os preguntaréis:
vale, Fonseca pero… ¿Hay algún ejemplo
de ciudad que sí haya solucionado el problema
de los alquileres? Pues sí. Ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver.
VIENA: ALQUILERES PARA TODOS
Austria es uno de los países más ricos de
Europa. El salario medio está por encima
de los 2.700 euros al mes. En Viena no es
raro conseguir contratos de 3500 euros al
mes. Sin embargo, los alquileres están al
nivel de una ciudad como Madrid. Por 1500
euros puedes encontrar un piso de 80 metros
cuadrados en el centro, por ejemplo.
Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando. Seguro que
ahora estos de VisualPolitik nos van a vender
cómo Viena es otro ejemplo más de libre
mercado que funciona maravillosamente bien
¿Verdad? Pues no. De hecho todo lo contrario.
Básicamente, el Ayuntamiento de Viena es
algo así como una empresa promotora y, a
la vez, el mayor casero de la ciudad. Veréis,
tras la II Guerra Mundial, medio Viena quedó
devastada por las bombas. Así que el consistorio
pagó las reparaciones de todas las casas.
Después dijeron “ya que hemos reconstruído
todas estas casas… ahora tenemos derecho
para alquilarlas con nuestras propias condiciones”.
Y así es como comenzó el programa de vivienda
pública más ambicioso del mundo. El 80%
de los vieneses viven de alquiler. Habéis
oído bien. Y el 60% de esos alquileres son
vivienda de protección oficial. Algunos de
los edificios pertenecen a cooperativas y
otros al ayuntamiento pero todos tienen precios
controlados.
¡Y esperad un momento porque no hablamos
de alquileres normales! En Viena, los contratos
de alquiler no sólo son para toda la vida
¡Es que también se pueden heredar! Es decir,
a efectos prácticos son algo así como una
propiedad limitada del piso. Siempre y cuando
no te mudes, es tuyo. Y, creedme, tenéis
que ver las casas. En Estados Unidos o Reino
Unido, las viviendas protegidas son sinónimo
de casas baratas y de mala calidad. Aquí
es todo lo contrario. Zonas comunes, piscina,
gimnasio y hasta saunas. En algunos casos,
podemos encontrarnos situaciones absurdas.
Preparando este vídeo, hablé con el Ayuntamiento
de Viena y me dieron varios casos. Por ejemplo,
una chica que vive en un apartamento de 100
metros cuadrados en el centro de Viena ¿Cuánto
creéis que paga? 400 euros al mes. Pues resulta
que su vecino, que vive en un piso similar,
paga 2000. Y diréis ¿Cómo es esto posible?
Pues muy sencillo… su vecino está en ese
40% de casas que no son de protección oficial.
Es decir, que al igual que en Estocolmo, aquí
tenemos dos tipos de alquiler: precio protegido
y precio libre. Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué
aquí no tienen listas de espera? Y aquí
tenéis la respuesta.
Anualmente, Viena se gasta alrededor de 600
millones de euros en viviendas sociales. En
comparación, Alemania, con una población
45 veces mayor, se gasta 400 millones en todo
el país.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero cómo funciona este
sistema? Pues bien, vamos a imaginar que os
mudáis a Viena. En un primer momento, no
podéis pedir un piso de protección oficial.
Pero ¡No pasa nada! Hay más de 290.000 pisos
que están en un mercado libre de alquiler.
Así que no es especialmente difícil encontrar
un sitio donde estar. Al cabo de 2 o 3 años,
ya podéis aplicar para una vivienda de Protección
Oficial. Dependiendo del estatus familiar,
los ingresos y vuestras propias preferencias,
podéis encontrar piso más pronto o más
tarde. Pero, normalmente, hablamos de tiempos
de espera de no más de 2 años. Por supuesto
que este modelo tiene sus desventajas. De
entrada, una vez has encontrado un piso que
te gusta, no te vas a ir de ahí ni con aguarrás.
De hecho, es un modelo que reduce bastante
la libertad de elección. Es el ayuntamiento
quien decide dónde vives y en qué condiciones.
Y, por supuesto, es un modelo que depende
demasiado de un único actor: el ayuntamiento.
Es decir, que mientras la administración
austriaca tenga dinero, no hay problema. Ahora
bien, bastaría una crisis para que Viena
dejara de construir. Pensadlo bien, con este
modelo, apenas hay incentivos para las empresas
privadas. Y en el momento en el cual la oferta
de pisos deje de aumentar, este modelo vienés
tendría muchos problemas.
Ahora bien, por el momento, hay que reconocer
que está funcionando. Así que ahora la pregunta
es ¿Sería posible combinar este modelo Vienés
con el libre mercado? ¿Creéis que se puede
exportar este sistema a vuestra ciudad? ¿Os
gustaría vivir siempre de alquiler si las
condiciones son buenas? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios.
Y antes de terminar, me gustaría dar las
gracias a Marc Solo y a Jaime Chapinal por
ayudarme con datos sobre los alquileres de
Estocolmo. También quiero dar las gracias
al Ayuntamiento de Viena, que me han contestado
a todas mis preguntas y han sido muy amables.
Y por supuesto, recordad que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas. Así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos nuestras actualizaciones. Si os
ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos
vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.